have you seen jamie since the football
roster went up yesterday
are you nervous he'll be pissed nah this
happened back at douglas
they'll be annoyed at first and they'll
shove a bunch of tampons in my locker
and then they'll get over it we work it
out on the field dude it's messed up
you're not starting quarterback
see and i don't like that it has to come
to this but
we know what has to happen next
you need to let us in take the feelings
helmet
[Music]
the feeling i'm doing is sad
and not a beautiful sad like uh the last
day of summer
it's an ugly sad like my mom told me i
had to put down my dog
actually now it's even worse than
putting down my dog because
i got to pick her back up again after i
finished my dinner
come on boys he needs us come on we got
you
you guys are really good huggers
maybe we'll work it out on the field
after he stops crying
very funny i give you a hard time about
feminism and you demote my son to teach
me a lesson
real mature man i wish that would have
been so cool
but no i was just doing what you said
let the stats speak for themselves of
course jaime's stats don't really speak
so much as they
drool and bang their spoon for more
oatmeal are you saying that jamie isn't
good
how could that possibly be true have you
ever been to any of his games
not exactly i'm afraid to see him get a
concussion to have a seat
check this out
did you fumble no i i don't know where i
put it
turn around
any questions i have a question i ate a
piece of chalk and now i
cannot see why did you even put him on
the team
at all i didn't remember jamie didn't
make the team
last year but then you marched in here
and guilted me into giving him a chance
kind of like i'm doing right now well
someone has to tell him he's not good
yeah someone does do you think it should
be like his pediatrician
or my friend cindy
it's me i know it's me or you
no you okay
you